it is forever summer in Malta but a
shadow looms over the Mediterranean
island allegations of crime and
corruption in big business and high
office
and now people want change journalist
and blogger Daphne karana Galicia delved
deep and ended up dead killed by a car
bomb in 2017 near her home her son
Matthew heard the blast when my mother
lived the house and a few minutes later
I heard the blast I knew straight away
that it was a car bomb so I ran out of
the house and I saw the fire I saw the
smoke but those absolutely nothing that
could be done this criminal organization
has taken control of every single lever
of the state and is using it to fire at
my mother as though she were our
country's greatest enemy three men
arrested in connection with the murder
are awaiting trial
last November 1 of Malta's richest
businessmen Jurgen Finnick was arrested
and charged with being an accomplice to
the killing he denies involvement fennec
implicated the Maltese prime ministers
chief of staff Keith Schembri as a
co-conspirator Schembri was interrogated
by police and released without charge he
later resigned the revelations led to
rare protests demanding prime minister
Joseph muskets immediate resignation
many think his office had a hand in the
journalist death muscat bowed to public
pressure and stepped down kick starting
a race to replace him former health
minister chris fern is the clear
favorite a few expect he'll be able to
cure Malta of its political ills I don't
think there will be overnight change
with regards to structural issues I
think the new leader which will be
eventually the new prime minister of
Malta alone will not be able and I don't
I don't think there is even the will to
change all this
in a final address to support us on
Friday Joseph says he took the decision
to resign for unity to win over have
something image crisis on the global
stage the question is whether a change
of leader will really make a difference
the European Union's watching the crisis
in its smallest member state closely
it's accused Malta of allowing dirty
money to flow into Europe using the
island as a backdoor Malta could lose EU
voting right if its next leader doesn't
bring crime under control Nev Barca al
Jazeera Valletta